what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of our
beyond omega level series where we
discuss the most powerful characters in
comics and for this video we're stepping
into the marvel cosmic hierarchy and
talking about a character with one of
the weirdest names in all of comics the
in-betweener now the in-betweener was
created by jim starlin and first
appeared in warlock number nine in 1975
and the way marvel's pantheon of cosmic
beings works is that each of them are
basically the embodiment of some aspect
of the universe and in the case of the
in-betweener he's the embodiment of the
concept of duality now we're first
introduced to the in-betweener during an
altercation between adam warlock and his
evil counterpart the magus who had one
of the best afros in the history of
comics now magus summons the
in-betweener and states that he rules a
realm between fact and fantasy and that
his domain is the land between reality
and illusion now when the in-betweener
shows up he informs adam warlock that he
does the bidding of two other cosmic
entities master order and lord chaos
which as the names imply are the
embodiments of order and chaos within
the marvel universe the in-betweener
also states that he walks between all
concepts including life and death
reality and illusion good and evil logic
and emotion and god and man and claims
that he has the ability to affect all of
those concepts which suggests that he's
capable of manipulating reality itself
now the next time that we see the
in-betweener it's in the pages of doctor
strange which jim starlin was writing at
the time and we see that the universe is
being changed in some drastic ways by a
group called the creators who were
basically just using a device called the
cosmic wheel of change now doctor
strange teams up with a living star
named apollo and destroys the cosmic
wheel of change which sent the cycle of
change already happening in the universe
spiraling out of control and so the
creators take on human form and are
basically able to do anything they want
including transforming humans into
bistro forms and they create a version
of doctor strange that's half human half
wild boar called dr stranger yet which
is kind of weird and if it sounds like a
ridiculous concept yeah i mean that's
what marvel comics were in the 1970s
right it was just weird but regardless
all this changing of reality also
affects the ancient one who had
basically merged his consciousness with
the universe but found the changes
happening to reality so disorienting and
painful that he was forced to find a
physical form to inhabit and doctor
strange later finds him lying drunk in
an alley where the two of them were
attacked by four servants of the
creators and so after defeating them the
ancient one opens a portal and takes
doctor strange to the realm of power
that's beyond the creators which is
beyond a being or force like dormammu
but is a concept much like eternity the
entity of course turns out to be the
in-betweener who the ancient one
describes as all-powerful and a
separator of actualities now we learned
that the in-betweener was created by
master order and lord chaos to bring
about the balance between life and death
in the universe which is why he was
attempting to bring about the
transformation of adam warlock into the
magus and when that failed he sought to
use the creators to bring about the
balance he desired but doctor strange
messes that up when he broke the cosmic
wheel of change now it's revealed that
the in-betweener is nearly omnipotent
and also capable of interdimensional
teleportation as he effortlessly sends
doctor strange to another dimension now
when strange and the in-betweener engage
in battle the in-betweener is unaffected
by any of dr strange's spells and
repeatedly alters reality as he sends
strange from one dimension to another in
rapid succession all while proclaiming
that he's more powerful than eternity
himself now doctor strange is
temporarily driven insane by how badly
he's being bested by the in-betweener
and the only way he's able to gain a
victory here is by calling on the power
of the in-betweener's creators master
order and lord chaos now at this point
in history doctor strange was vastly
more powerful than he is now so the fact
that the in-betweener was just able to
wipe the floor with him with no
difficulty just shows how powerful this
guy is like quite literally doctor
strange had a magical spell for pretty
much anything he wanted to do now the
in-betweener then forges an alliance
with the elders of the universe a group
of extremely powerful entities such as
the collector and ego the living planet
all in an attempt to kill galactus now
the elders seek to destroy galactus
because they believe that doing so will
basically result in the balance between
death and eternity being disrupted which
would bring about the end of the
universe itself and so the elders
restore the in-betweener from the
mystical prison where he was imprisoned
by order and chaos and he sets off to
kill galactus now the battle between
galactus and the in betweener is
basically a stalemate until the elders
decide to help galactus using five of
the infinity stones and master order in
lord chaos once again imprison the
in-betweener but later as thanos began
his quest for the infinity gems he frees
the in-betweener from his prison as the
in-betweener had the soul stone embedded
in his forehead and so thanos of course
steals the stone and then leads the
in-betweener to deal with the
consequences of escaping chaos and
orders prison which presumably means
they end up punishing him in some way
anyway but during jonathan hickman's
time runs out storyline we saw the
in-betweener along with master order
lord chaos and all the rest of the
cosmic entities had all basically been
killed by the beyonders but after the
marvel universe is reformed he appears
once again this time in al ewing's
ultimates 2 series which was amazing in
this story we end up learning that
master order and lord chaos have
basically teamed up to kill the living
tribunal who's the personification of
law and judgment and seek to establish a
new hierarchy and so to achieve this
they decide to replace the living
tribunal and fill his role as the
personification of law themselves but to
do that they order the in-betweener to
be the catalyst for the two of them to
merge into one being called logos now
eventually logos is torn apart and
separates into its individual components
of master order lord chaos and the
in-betweener and this is really the last
time that we've seen him show up in the
marvel universe so yeah he's an
incredibly powerful character that's
nearly omnipotent he can basically do
anything he wants through his ability to
manipulate cosmic energy and alter
reality itself to achieve his desired
purpose of bringing about balance with
the only limit to his power being that
he is wholly subservient to master order
in lord chaos the in-betweener also
possesses an ability to discern the
exact energy that will be the polar
opposite of any opponent he's facing and
use it against them killing them
instantly he's also stated that he
believes himself to be the opposite of
galactus because his abilities don't
work on galactus which would explain why
neither of the two were able to gain a
meaningful advantage over the other
whenever it was that they fought so
having said that guys this is the
in-betweener this dude is op super
powerful but a lot of folks have been
asking for him so i figured we'd do them
if you guys want to see anybody else let
me know down in the comment section
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace